[Music]
and
you'll find help
[Music]
don't change the plank double playing
this again if those two points closer
together
Blaine
[Music]
there's anything that Android years you
can get hanged or znz and get the elbow
keep it in the same plane
just feel its weight you can do it
with movement
but it states only nothing and that's my
deal with
this again it's begin space that allows
me to manipulate the elbow by leading it
so that I can get underneath me so I can
do it up I go like this I'm keeping it
out from under me you see that that's
what most of you do and then when you
start to turn your further out or you
don't turn as you know you're going to
go further out and or shove them in okay
so it's standard ego it up you have to
figure out okay how do I get that elbow
to be like so I can lead it now my in
space is gonna go around this time so
last time this hands mean this way this
time this has a little that way but not
in your normal cutting fashion hmm
that's now you're about to hear so I
need this day feeling goes around
but again dislike this time to go to the
end so I can get its elbow this hand
goes here so I didn't sell boy do you
have to resist the temptation to fight
that you met it go it's almost like it's
not it's not mine anymore but it's not
his it's ours and I'm going to go around
the arc point you understand until I
make the elbow my point that's my elbow
okay
not my wrist ours my elbow
Hey okay so I figured out the yen I have
the elbow and now what I end up doing is
a business how did that happen well
there was there's an X amount of degree
of rotation you can do that you need to
do depending on how much initial forward
progress we have okay that's how sharp
like an intern is what you're doing it
whatever that rate is we'll call it X
whatever X is you're doing less than X
and you come in here and the arm
straightens out again it's happening
because the this hand is not your
controlling hand you're still dealing
with they grabbed you and you're still
fighting that point so you go to pull it
and now you're straight be strong be
strong be strong okay and you're not
gonna get them down so in your culture
everybody went false and you think that
works but just Keynesian logically it
doesn't work okay it's definitely not
Aikido if you don't have to arrest
anyone or whatever you're gonna find out
it doesn't work you can't just armbar
people okay so I need his elbow to
continue to point down
and that's what helps his shoulder aim
down and when you go here his shoulders
not pointing down you see so you keep
this circle going you see so then his
shoulder points down I'm not pinning him
down I'm leading him down
[Music]
okay let's try we want to get out of the
beginner level it is where when do I
turn okay so I'm gonna turn in a way
that that arm stays underneath me so
what's guiding me is this arm that's
gonna determine should I bring my knee
in should I step out should I rotate I
have more living here whatever I'm going
to turn in a way that that elbow stays
underneath when do you open your legs
and akiza I will open my legs and akiza
when that elbow is down on the ground
okay it's telling me where to go
all right yeah he's taller than me so if
we sit down right it's not that big 100
change and so you can get you can get
the elbow underneath your Center a
little more easily because your Center
right it's harder but it's beginning
hand look it's um in the same spot now
you see and some of you don't do that
again you're just like how they how do
you do it go to the outside you're the
outside in but now it's not there and
now you have to go
I'm gonna work so how much you'd wear to
get it underneath you
[Music]
Hey
it looks to you like what gonna be in
going to be is not is so right in the
middle that's gonna tell me where I turn
by turn you'll lead shifty right and
you're grounding your routing is
community to play so alright ok I did
everything right but I'm not moving
right see I'm rooted I could push she
pushes on me I'm not gonna go anywhere
okay so now it's time to shift my weight
and to pivot my feet and what you're
doing instead is your center of gravity
is coming behind the posted foot here so
you go here you see that I supposed to
stay over the posted foot I'm on the
posted foot there's no weight on this
foot okay and I'm turning on the posted
foot yeah
so you're here and then you wait shift
to the back so that you can move this
leg
and then that's what causes this
separation on center but when you go
like that it started to move right and
when you put your foot there this to the
outside as opposed to ground ground
above this foot when I turn I'm turning
you see the weight shift I turn on it
this foot is now not doing anything but
moving and I pivot on the ruby foot okay
so it might just be here and then root
and that's all I need I'm not going to
move it away the first move is yeah